welcome to the David Pakman show I'm
Benjamin Dixon filling in one more time
for David while he is away are on his
way back from sitting in with Joe Rogan
if you didn't get a chance to watch it
you should definitely watch it it was a
lot of good parts in there I'm going to
play a clip of David later on in another
segment but definitely check out his
interview with Joe Rogan I think it was
great let's start by talking about the
need to impeach this president there's a
lot of there's a lot of questions
whether or not this is politically
viable but there's a clip from Elizabeth
Warren as she makes the case while you
know it while we may question the
political validity of impeaching
President Trump and whether or not it's
going to be politically useful for
Democrats to actually do that the case
is clear so I want to play this clip
from Elizabeth Warren and then I want to
go over 7 articles of impeachment that
was pub that were published in The
Washington Post and by journalist max
boob but first let's take a look at
Elizabeth Warren's case the molar report
came out and the afternoon it came out I
set out and started reading it and I
read it all afternoon I read it all
night I read it into the next morning
all 448 pages I got to the end and there
were three things that are just man
there's no avoiding part one a hostile
foreign government attacked our 2016
elections for the purpose of getting
Donald Trump elected part two then
candidate Donald Trump welcomed that
help and part three when the federal
government tried to investigate Part one
and Part two Donald Trump as president
delayed deflected move fired and did
everything he could to obstruct justice
if he were any other person in the
United States based on what's documented
in that report he would be carried out
in handcuffs so Warren makes a
compelling case I think she's making a
very firm case and she's using quite
frankly this is what I would personally
want to see from Nancy Pelosi I think
there is a case
to impeach Donald Trump now there's an
article 7 impeachment seven reasons to
impeach Trump and I want to go over just
those seven articles and then there is
the one big reason to not impeach Trump
but we're gonna address that as well I
want to bring the first article of
impeachment up on the screen that was
prepared by max boot in his article for
The Washington Post and he said article
one Donald Trump in violation of his
oath to preserve protect and defend the
Constitution and take care of the laws
take care that the laws be faithfully
executed has obstructed administer the
administration of justice and then max
boot goes and to give gives all the
examples of the firing of of James Comey
the attempt to block the investigation
by Bob Muller he outlines it's clearly
there and these are all things that are
outlined in the Muller report and
remember before we go any further
remember that Muller said in his speech
last week that had they found or rather
had they not found evidence he said it
very it was very interesting he said it
he said if they had not if they found
evidence that the President did not
commit a crime they would have told
America in other words they could not
find a case to say that Donald Trump did
not commit a crime it was it's
interesting wordplay that he used there
but it's very clear he was letting
America know that there's something here
and so max Buu continues article to
Donald Trump in violation of his oath to
preserve protect and defend the
Constitution and to take the take care
that the laws be faithfully executed
failed to defend America from foreign
election interference article three
Donald Trump in violation of his oath to
preserve protect and defend the
Constitution and to take the care that
the laws be faithfully executed
attempted to investigate and prosecute
his political opponents this one is
actually interesting as far as whether
or not this becomes a an impeachable
offense he's outlining it here but it is
it is something that is extremely
concerning that almost as a reaction
almost as a you know as a way of
intimidating his political opponents are
intimidating the opposition in general
he's using the force of the Justice
Department to try to silence his
opposition continuing on article four
J Trump in violation of his oath to
preserve protect and defend the
Constitution and to take care that the
laws be faithfully executed failed to
produce papers and testimony as duly
directed by Congress Donald Trump in
violation of federal campaign finance
laws conspired with his attorney Michael
Cohen in order to conceal alleged
relationships with adult film actress
stormy Daniels and Playboy Playmate
Karen McDougal before the 2016 election
article 6 Donald Trump in violation of
his oath to uphold article 1 section 9
of the Constitution and he quoted here
no money shall be drawn from the
Treasury but in consequence of
appropriations made by law attempted to
misuse his emergency powers to spend
funds on a border wall that Congress did
not appropriate so this is a really this
is a good one
I find this one's interesting because it
really puts an emphasis on the fact that
so much happens in this in this
administration that is already an
impeachable offense that goes under the
radar because of how really insane our
news cycle is like the fact that Donald
Trump is actively trying to use the
emergency his emergency powers to get
money to fund the wall and just because
he wants to circumvent Congress is in
fact an impeachable offense but he has
so many impeachable offenses that it's
almost like you know no big deal and
that's also a product of Donald Trump's
his methodology of throwing so much
causing so much chaos that it's
impossible to just make one thing stick
last but not least article 7 Donald
Trump in violation of his oath to uphold
the molle mints calls and he cites it
here which forbid the comma the
president from accepting benefits from
foreign and state governments without
permission of Congress retains ownership
of a global business empire which allows
him to benefit from dealing with
dillings with foreign and state
governments now this this is the own
this has been going on almost since day
one and again it falls underneath that
category of so many things happening in
this administration that it's impossible
for for Congress to keep up isn't it's
almost impossible for the media to keep
up and this is a strategy so there are
seven seven articles of impeachment that
journalists max boot
drew up according to our based on rather
the mullah report the case is there I
mean the legal case to impeach President
Trump is there there's just one big
reason for them not to impeach Donald
Trump and that that reason really hinges
on whether or not they whether or not
Republicans will find him guilty in the
Senate there's an article that uh that
was that was done by Lawrence tribe
Harvard attorney Lawrence tribe and he
just making the case that you absolutely
have the legal justification a reason to
impeach Donald Trump the question is
whether or not the Senate the Republican
controls said it is going to actually
find them guilty and actually I can
correct myself it's not a question we
all know Mitch McConnell is not going to
find no one in the none of not a single
Republican is going to find Donald Trump
guilty on any of these counts right and
so the belief is that because of that
Donald Trump will be able to take a
victory lap and use it to score
political points and see I've been
completely vindicated now this is this
is this goes counter to what happened
with Bill Clinton Bill Clinton who was
also not found guilty in the Senate
trial you know he did not run a victory
lap Bill Clinton did not rub it in the
faces of America or his political
opposition
he took it almost humbly he was humbled
by the fact that he was not found guilty
in that impeachment trial but we're
dealing with a different monster we're
dealing dealing with a different breed
of subhuman by the name of Donald Trump
because he absolutely is going to run up
the scoreboard on the fact that the
Senate which is controlled by
Republicans and they're not they're
never going to find him guilty so it's
already baked in the system but that
will not stop Donald Trump from actually
trying to leverage it for as many
political points as he possibly can so
you have seven reasons to impeach Donald
Trump given by max vote and you have
this one reason that Nancy Pelosi is
talking about on a regular basis or
she's not saying it directly but that's
what she's afraid of now Lawrence tribe
who I mentioned he also has an article
in The Washington Post an attorney he's
making the case that listen Congress can
impeach Donald Trump
I'll actually pushing this to a trial in
the Senate so in other words you can use
impeachment as a way of exposing to the
entire world particularly to America
what Donald Trump has done his crimes
and misdemeanors as high crimes and
misdemeanors but you don't necessarily
have to trigger the Senate the Senate
trial and that way you can actually get
the best of both worlds you can do your
due diligence you could do your job as
the body that should begin the
impeachment inquiry and draw up articles
of impeachment and then do that to hold
the president accountable for all the
things that he has legitimate he's
literally done these things but they're
afraid to do their job in the House of
Representatives because of what will
happen when the Senate finds Donald
Trump not guilty and so where we have
seven reasons why he should be impeached
there's just one huge reason why Nancy
Pelosi is not going to do it and now we
see that there's a possibility article
in The Washington Post Lawrence tribe
he's making the case and actually I read
that case for you really quickly he says
quote the house assuming an impeachment
inquiry leads to a conclusion of Trump's
guilt could choose between presenting
articles of impeachment even to a Senate
pre committed to burying them and
dispensing with impeachment as such
while embodying its conclusions of
criminality or other grave wrongdoing in
a condemnatory sense of the house
resolution
far stronger than a mere censure the
resolution expressly informally
proclaiming the president's impeachable
but declining to play the Senate's
corrupt corrupt game is one that even a
president accustomed to treating
everything as a victory would be
hard-pressed to characterize as
vindication so essentially they can more
or less impeach the president with
something that's far more than a censure
but does not allow it to be taken into
the hands of the corrupt Senate
underneath the control of Mitch
McConnell which there's no way in the
world
everyone knows they'll never find Donald
Trump guilty of these things so this is
the pullet mean this is the world of
politics it's frustrating we have a
president who in any other circuit
since like Elizabeth Warren would be in
handcuffs but here we have a president
and because of the nature of our hyper
partisan politics we have seven reasons
to impeach them and there's just as huge
reason this number one reason why they
probably will never impeach them